T
ADVENTURE WILL COME TO AN UGLY
END.
JOINING ME AND I WAS WISCONSIN
CONGRESSMAN MIKE GALLAGHER WHO
WILL CHAIR THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CHINA AND THE NEW CONGRESS.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON THESE ISSUES THAT WE
RAISED IN "THE ANGLE."
CAN YOU PROMISE ESTIMATE THAT
THE G.O.P. LEADERSHIP IS NOT
GOING TO TRY TO SELL US AGAIN ON
THIS TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP
THAT YOU HEARD BOB LIGHTHIZER,
WORLD EXPERT ON TRADE AGREEMENTS
ABSOLUTELY SAY SHOULD BE A
NONSTARTER?
>> I HEARD NO DISCUSSION OF IT
IN CONGRESS.
I CAN IMAGINE IT'S GOING TO BE A
PRIORITY.
IF WE ARE INTERESTED IN DOING
ANYTHING ON TRADE, I THINK THERE
SOME LOW-HANGING FRUIT.
A FREE-TRADE AGREEMENT WITH
TAIWAN ITSELF WHICH IS MIRED IN
DISAGREEMENT RIGHT NOW.
IF WE WANT TO PURSUE A TRADE
AGREEMENT, BILATERAL TRADE
AGREEMENT WOULD MAKE FAR MORE
SENSE AS WELL AS A POST BREXIT
GOLD STANDARD TRADE AGREEMENT
WITH THE U.K. WHICH IS
COMPLETELY FOLLOWED BY THE
WAYSIDE.
IF YOU WANT TO DRAW CLOSER
ECONOMICALLY AND TECHNOLOGICALLY
WITH OUR ALLIES, LET'S THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN SHARE
INTERMEDIATE RANGE MISSILE
TECHNOLOGY WITH THE AUSSIES FOR
EXAMPLE, NOW THAT WE ARE NO
LONGER BOUND BY THE INF TREATY
BECAUSE TRUMP SMARTLY GOT OUT OF
IT.
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT HOW
WE SELECTIVELY DECOUPLE
TECHNOLOGICALLY, ECONOMICALLY,
FINANCIALLY.
IN TERMS OF DATA AND DOLLARS
FROM CHINA.
POTENTIALLY REMOVING PERMANENT
NORMAL TRADE RELATIONS FROM
CHINA, NOT ALLOWING THEM TO GAME
THE GLOBAL TRADING SYSTEM.
>> Laura: THAT'S MUSIC TO THE
VIEWERS OF "THE ANGLE," THEIR
EARS.
IT'S BEEN A COMPLETE LOSER FOR
THE AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS.
AS YOU HEARD, COMMERCE SECRETARY
GINA RAIMONDO IS CONFUSING TO
SAY WE SHOULD DECOUPLE FROM
CHINA.
WHAT YOU JUST REFERENCE.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT OUR
SO-CALLED ALLIES WON'T EVEN
ENTERTAIN THE DISCUSSION OF
GETTING TOUGH ON CHINA,
SHOULDN'T WE BEGIN TO DO THIS
OURSELVES?
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
THEY CHEAT US BLIND ON TRADE.
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE A
SLAVE STATE.
>> THERE'S THREE URGENT THINGS I
THINK WE NEED TO DO.
THE FIRST IS TO ENSURE U.S.
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT GOING INTO
CHINA'S MILITARY MODERNIZATION
OR ABETTING CHINA'S GENOCIDE.
THE SECOND THING IS TO CUT OFF
THE FLOW OF U.S. DOLLARS.
IN PARTICULAR, TAX-ADVANTAGED
ENTITIES, TAX EXEMPT ENTITIES.
THINK HIGHER EDUCATION,
UNIVERSITY ENDOWMENTS SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO INVEST IN CHINA.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
ARE LECTURING US ABOUT ESG
INVESTING.
CHINA STINKS.
IF THE G STANDS FOR ANYTHING IT
SHOULD STAND FOR GENOCIDE HERE
WE NEED TO DECOUPLE IN TERMS OF
DATA.
THIS STARTS WITH TIKTOK.
IT'S LONG PAST TIME WE BAN
TIKTOK.
WE DON'T HAVE A RECIPROCAL DATA
ARRANGEMENT WITH CHINA AND THEY
EFFECTIVELY CONTROL THE APP AND
ALGORITHMS ARE HIGHLY ADDICTIVE,
HIGHLY DEADLY AND THEY ALLOWED
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY TO
EFFECTIVELY SELECTIVELY EDIT THE
NEWS.
WE DO NOT WANT THE CCP TO
CONTROL THE LARGEST MEDIA
COMPANY IN AMERICA.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, WHY IS
A COMMUNIST COUNTRY ALLOWED TO
BUY U.S. REAL ESTATE, U.S. MAJOR
AGRICULTURAL COMPANIES, FOOD
COMPANIES, IN LARGE TRACTS OF
REAL ESTATE NEAR MILITARY BASES.
WHY IS THAT ALLOWED?
>> IT'S AN ISSUE WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO LOOK INTO ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CHINA.
IT SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED.
CRITICALLY THAT THERE IS A CLEAR
AFFILIATION WITH THE PLA.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS THEY HIDE
THESE CONNECTIONS SOMETIME
THROUGH OPAQUE ARRANGEMENTS.
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT AT LEAST SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF THE 2017 NATIONAL
SECURITY LAW IN CHINA, THERE'S
REALLY NO SUCH THING AS A
PRIVATE COMPANY IN CHINA.
EVERYONE IS CONTROLLED BY THE
CCP, SUBJECTED TO THE DIRECTION
OF THE CCP AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHO WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
IT'S A GENOCIDAL COMMUNIST
REGIME THAT NOT ONLY WANTS TO
OPPRESS THEIR OWN CITIZENS,
SUCCEED WHERE THE SOVIET UNION
FAILED IN PERFECTING THE MODEL
OF TOTAL PARTY CONTROL BUT
INCREASINGLY TO EXPORT THAT
MODEL AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY TALK OPENLY ABOUT
DESTROYING THE CAPITALIST SYSTEM
LED BY THE UNITED STATES IN
ORDER TO MAKE WAY FOR THE
TRIUMPH OF WORLD SOCIALISM WITH
CHINESE CHARACTERISTICS AND
SLOWLY THEY HAVE TURNED US INTO
A NATION OF ADDICTS, ADDICTED TO
CHEAP CHINESE GOODS, ADDICTED TO
FENTANYL, ADDICTED TO CCP
ALGORITHMS.
>> Laura: LOOKING FORWARD TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
COMMITTEE, WE APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US.
HAVE A MERRY CHRISTMAS.
CURRENT AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
ISN'T JUST SABOTAGING THE
COUNTRY ABROAD BUT WITHIN AS
WELL.
THE MAINSTREAMING OF POT TEST,
THE SAME TIME AS THE DRUG HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY IN ITS
POTENCY, ITS THC LEVELS.
AS ONE HIGHLY CITED PAPER POINTS
OUT, THE CONSUMPTION OF
MARIJUANA IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
INCREASE IN VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AND
A HIGH RISK OF PSYCHOSIS FOR
FREQUENT USERS.
THESE ISSUES ARE NOT OF CONCERN
LOOK INTO THOSE TO CASH IN ON
THIS BURGEONING BUSINESS.
DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY THE
"L.A. TIMES" SHOW THAT CANNABIS
COMPANIES AND INVESTORS PROVIDED
SOME OF THE EARLY FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR UCLA'S CANNABIS
RESEARCH INITIATIVE.
THEY FUNDED IT.
WRITING CHECKS FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
DONATIONS AND ASSISTING WITH
FUND-RAISING EVENTS.
THEY AREN'T ALONE.
HARVARD, MIT, UC SAN DIEGO ARE
AMONG THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ACCEPTED MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
GIFTS IN RECENT YEARS.
JOINING ME NOW IS LUKE,
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
SMART APPROACHES TO MARIJUANA.
LUKE, THE RESEARCH FOR HOW SAFE
AND GREAT WEED IS, SOME OF THE
DOLLARS ARE COMING FROM THE LEAD
LOBBY.
ARE WE GETTING THIS RIGHT?
>> YEAH, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
BIG MARIJUANA IS TERRIFIED.
THERE ARE VOLUMES OF RESEARCH
TELLING US THAT THIS NEW
SUPERCHARGED MARIJUANA THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS PUMPING OUT IS
CAUSING PSYCHOSIS,
SCHIZOPHRENIA.
WE ARE SEEING ADDICTION RATES GO
UP, THEY ARE TARGETING OUR KIDS,
CAR CRASHES ON THE ROADS.
ALL THIS IS COMING OUT IN THE
RESEARCH SO THEY GO TO THEIR BIG
BROTHER TOBACCO WHO, BY THE WAY,
IS THEIR BIGGEST INVESTOR AND
THEY START PUMPING OUT FAKE,
BOGUS RESEARCH.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT FUNDED
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
UCLA'S RESEARCH ON MARIJUANA,
THAT COMPANY WAS CALLED NUGS.
NOT RUN BY SIR ISAAC NEWTON.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO ADVANCE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH, THEY ARE
PLAYING FOR PUBLICITY AND
MISINFORMATION WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT BIG TOBACCO DID.
THEY KILLED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS TO MAKE A BUCK AND
THAT'S WHAT MARIJUANA WANTS TO
DO WITH THEIR BIG TOBACCO
INVESTORS.
>> Laura: IT IS CORRUPT TO THE
CORE.
YOU CHAT WITH FOLKS WHO MAYBE
DON'T READ UP ON THIS OR HAVEN'T
REALLY FOLLOWED WHAT HE DOES,
ESPECIALLY TO THE YOUNG BRAIN
WITH FREQUENT USE, THEY SAY IT'S
BETTER FOR YOU THAN ALCOHOL.
IT RELAXES YOU.
ALL THE MEDICINAL BENEFITS.
TO THAT, YOU SAY?
>> WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THE ALCOHOL
THING, I SAY IF YOU HAVE A CAR
AND YOU JUST BROKE YOUR
HEADLIGHT, DO YOU SAY OKAY, TO
BE CONSISTENT, LET ME SMASH IN
MY TAILLIGHT?
WE HAVE ISSUES WITH ALCOHOL.
MORE THAN 100,000 AMERICANS DIE
EVERY YEAR RELATED TO ALCOHOL.
IT'S NOT LIKE THAT'S GOING
GREAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT MARIJUANA, YOU
HAVE THE INDUSTRY PEDDLING THESE
LIES.
MARIJUANA HELPS WITH ANXIETY.
WE HAVE TEN RESEARCH STUDIES
THAT JUST CAME OUT IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THAT TELL YOU
MARIJUANA ACTUALLY MAKES ANXIETY
WORSE.
YOU HEAR THESE CLAIMS, MARIJUANA
IS NOT ADDICTIVE THAT THE DATA
ARE TELLING US FROM OUR NATIONS
AND MOST REVERED RESEARCHERS
THAT ONE IN THREE PEOPLE WHO USE
MARIJUANA IN THE LAST YEAR WILL
DEVELOP A CANNABIS USE DISORDER.
THAT'S THE MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS FOR
ADDICTION.
THERE IS THESE MYTHS THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO UNDERMINE
YOUR WE NEED REAL SCIENCE, NOT
BOGUS SCIENCE.
>> Laura: IT REMINDS ME A LOT
OF THE COVERT, YOU KNOW FUNDING,
OF RESEARCH STUDIES WITH COVID.
IT REMINDS ME A LOT OF THA